Traductor: Larisa Esteche
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Todos alguna vez
hemos escuchado frases como:
"Corres como niña", "pegas como niña",
"Tú cállate, mejor ve a lavar los platos".
"Maneja pésimo, seguramente es vieja".
O una frase que recientemente leí
que decía,
"todas las mujeres son independientes
hasta el momento en que tienen que cargar
un garrafón".
Si nos damos cuenta, todas estas frases
responden a un tema
de fuerza y coordinación y es cierto,
las mujeres, fisiológicamente,
tenemos menos fuerza respecto a un hombre.
Sin embargo, he visto mujeres que,
por ejemplo,
quieren abrir una botella de agua
y se la entregan al hombre
más cercano que tienen,
como si ellas no fueran capaces
de realizar esta simple acción.
Muchas veces, la dependencia comienza
por nosotras mismas
y no nos percatamos de eso.
Y así como tú, yo también he vivido
las consecuencias del machismo
en mi vida cotidiana.
Les cuento, yo soy deportista
de alto rendimiento
y, nosotras como deportistas,
podemos reducir esta brecha de fuerza
entre hombres y mujeres,
e inclusive podemos ser más fuertes
que un hombre promedio
que no está involucrado,
que no ha estado involucrado
durante toda su vida con el deporte,
pero porque nosotras
entrenamos 5 horas al día,
y llevamos años y años de entrenamiento.
Dicho esto, les cuento una historia
que comúnmente me pasa en el gimnasio
donde, por ejemplo, estoy alternando
algún aparato con un muchachón,
y me preguntan como por defecto,
"¿Cuánto peso quieres que le quite?
No te vayas a lesionar, yo te apoyo".
Cuando en realidad, la pregunta
debería ser, en mi caso,
"¿Cuánto peso le añado?"
porque en varias ocasiones
cargo más que ellos.
¿Qué es lo que pasa con esto?
Desde que somos niños,
se nos asignan roles de género
de forma consciente, inconsciente,
normalizada,
y esto va generando estereotipos.
Me acuerdo, en un curso de verano,
cuando era niña,
que mis amigas se quedaban viendo
a los niños jugar fútbol,
echándoles porras en un rol
claramente pasivo
mientras que yo era la única niña
que, a la par de ellos,
subía, metía goles, o bajaba a defender.
Estas historias que les cuento
no necesariamente nos dejan
con una sensación de violencia,
sin embargo,
nos catalogan como el sexo débil,
el que no está capacitado,
el que no es apto, o el que no tiene
una oportunidad para jugar,
ejemplo, una cascarita.
Y estas situaciones son las que llamamos
micromachismos.
Todas estas situaciones
en nuestra cotidianidad
que vivimos y, sin darnos cuenta,
contienen una carga de machismo
pero no nos percatamos.
Siempre voy a estar agradecida
con la familia,
los valores, las vivencias
que hasta el día de hoy compartimos.
Yo provengo de una familia
donde la equidad de género
es lo normal y no una rareza,
donde jamás se me asignaron
tareas domésticas por el simple hecho
de ser mujer,
y donde viví siempre entre dos situaciones
totalmente extremas.
Por una parte, mi papá siempre
alentaba en mí actitudes de fuerza,
lucha, ser tosca, ruda, sin miedo a nada,
mientras que por otra parte, mi mamá
siempre forjó una niña femenina,
delicada, sensible, muchas veces ingenua
y totalmente sobreprotegida.
A medida que fui creciendo,
me vinculé con los hombres
de diferentes formas, por ejemplo,
en noviazgos,
y viví de forma sutil
lo que es el machismo
enmascarado tras este concepto
que hemos forjado socialmente
como "caballerosidad"
donde me hacían la vida más sencilla,
no tenía por qué preocuparme,
todo lo tenía resuelto,
y le cedí a alguien
parte de mi independencia.
Justamente esto, mi independencia,
fue lo que yo fui a rescatar, a revivir,
a retomar a Exatlón,
el reality show más exitoso
de todos los tiempos
en la televisión mexicana.
Espero que alguien por acá lo haya visto.
Y si no lo vieron, les voy a contar
qué es esto.
Exatlón es una competencia
de alto rendimiento,
y en mi generación de supervivencia
éramos 20 competidores.
Estábamos divididos en dos equipos.
El equipo azul, el contendiente es el mío.
Y el equipo de famosos, el rojo.
Dentro de esos participantes
había deportistas amateurs,
centroamericanos,
panamericanos, olímpicos,
había boxeadores profesionales,
futbolistas profesionales, actrices,
que semanalmente vivíamos la posibilidad
de ser eliminados de esta competencia
por nuestro rendimiento físico,
o también por la decisión del público.
Les voy a contar un poco
cómo era un circuito
para que sientan la vibra
que nosotros vivíamos
y también la gente detrás de la pantalla.
Eran aproximadamente 100 m
donde había muchísimos obstáculos.
Teníamos que saltar, correr, nadar,
nos caíamos, nos levantábamos.
Muchas veces nos lesionábamos
y llegábamos a esa parte final
que eran tiros de precisión,
así que imagínense llegar así
(Gasp)
con 180 pulsaciones y teníamos que tener
el temple, la seguridad, la concentración,
que era muy difícil, para embocar
por ejemplo 5 pelotas en un aro.
Y así obteníamos un punto.
Si les tengo que confesar por qué accedí
a participar en esta competencia,
no fue necesariamente por ser la ganadora
de los 2 millones de pesos
que era el gran premio,
o por ser famosa y salir en la tele.
Estaba atravesando, como cualquiera
de nosotros hemos atravesado alguna vez,
una relación... ¡no! Un noviazgo,
porque no era una relación,
un noviazgo tóxico
que me estaba haciendo la vida
día a día muy complicada
y decidí tomarme un break.
La impresión de todas las personas
que me rodeaban
es que iba a regresar de
esta competencia muy rápido,
o sea, que me iban a eliminar pronto,
y la cuestión no era la capacidad física,
sino más bien mi personalidad,
el contexto del que vengo,
que no empataban claramente
con lo que nos iban a hacer vivir allá,
que era una especie
de selección natural artificial.
Una historia que tengo súper presente,
ahora la tomo a la ligera
pero en su momento no me dio gracia,
es que una chica, de forma muy directa,
en nuestro primer desayuno como equipo
me dijo de forma súper frontal y directa
algo así como, "¿Y tú qué haces aquí?
Te ves toda femenina, fresa,
súper consentida,
¿sabes en qué te estás metiendo?".
Por cierto, esta chica
fue la primera eliminada,
le mando saludos,
y también una enseñanza de esto
es que todos siempre nos presentamos
teniendo prejuicios y estereotipos
y no deberían ser así las cosas.
¿Qué fue lo que en realidad pasó?
Resulté ser la mujer finalista
de esta competencia con 5 meses
vividos en República Dominicana
en las condiciones más sufridas,
difíciles, puedo decir también
traumáticas, insalubres,
que se puedan imaginar.
Pero también, en concreto,
los 5 mejores meses
que han marcado
un antes y un después en mi vida
y que siempre voy a estar agradecida
porque se me dio esta oportunidad.
Y si pudiera definir en tres etapas
lo que viví,
la primera sería shock por conocer
a lo que íbamos a estar sometidos
durante tanto tiempo.
La segunda, desesperación,
porque quería salir de ahí y no podía,
había firmado un contrato,
estaba totalmente atrapada.
Y la tercera, adaptación.
En esa etapa, me había adaptado
físicamente, espiritualmente,
deportivamente, fisiológicamente.
Todo lo que se me presentaba
lo resolvía de la mejor forma.
Nada me sorprendía, nada me daba miedo.
Llegué a estar en un estado zen
que jamás había experimentado
en el que solo me importaban tres cosas,
como que me volví muy animal,
muy básica.
Me importaba sobrevivir,
me importaba que mi idea de Dios
estuviera orgulloso de lo que hacía,
y la última, no fallarle a mi compañero
de equipo, Ernesto Cazares.
En una etapa muy difícil de la competencia
en la que solo quedábamos 2 representantes
del equipo de contendientes,
que constantemente
nos estábamos enfrentando
ante 5 grandes oponentes,
entre los que había deportistas olímpicos
y panamericanos,
y que literal, siempre sacaban
nuestra mejor versión,
y ¿qué fue lo que pasó?
Uno a uno los fuimos eliminando
y llegamos mi compañero y yo
juntos a la final en una historia
que realmente se veía imposible,
pero la hicimos posible,
y otra enseñanza que nos deja esto
es que jamás en la vida
hay un competidor débil.
La final soñada entre la audiencia,
entre la misma producción,
me imagino también
entre los propios participantes,
era entre dos hombres,
los dos más rápidos de los circuitos.
Sin embargo, el desenlace fue diferente.
Al ser una mujer y un hombre
los que tenían que competir,
no se nos dio la oportunidad
de competir físicamente
porque se creía que las condiciones
iban a ser injustas
y, por lo tanto, la audiencia
por medio de votos
decidió quién iba a ser el ganador.
Esta fue la primera vez en mi vida
donde me sentí como esas niñas
que les conté al principio,
en ese curso de verano,
donde nos sientan,
donde no nos dejan ser protagonistas
de una historia que nos pertenece
y donde, simplemente,
no se nos da ese voto de confianza.
Independientemente, fuese cual fuese
el resultado de esta competencia,
a mí me hubiera gustado
competir contra un hombre
por el poderoso mensaje
de equidad de género
que se hubiera dado a la audiencia
que nos veía
y que tanta urgencia y falta hace
en nuestra sociedad.
Muchas veces, riéndome
pero también muy seria,
le digo a ese muchachito de ahí
que me hubiera gustado
competir contra él de forma física,
y también le he comentado
que si no se hubiera puesto buzo
en la parte final de los tiros
de precisión donde todo se definía,
le hubiera ganado, porque después
de 5 meses de volverme obsesiva
con el entrenamiento de tiros,
de ser la peor al definir
me volví una máster.
Y bueno, a mí me pueden decir subcampeona,
el segundo lugar de esta competencia,
pero como en realidad me siento
es como la campeona femenina
de Exatlón, y no solo por las condiciones
físicas demostradas ahí,
sino también por todos los aprendizajes,
todas las vivencias,
todo el crecimiento personal que obtuve.
Algo curioso sobre el machismo
es que bueno,
cuando regresé de esta experiencia
me topé con todos los comentarios
que se habían dicho
sobre mí y sobre todos los participantes.
Pero bueno, los comentarios eran como,
"La final fue un fraude",
"A Macky la ayudaron a llegar
hasta la final",
"Tenía amigos en la producción",
"Tenía compadres en la producción",
"Tenía relaciones sentimentales
con alguien de la producción".
Ah, otra hipótesis era
"Su familia había comprado la final".
Y obviamente, después de tantas
molestias vividas en estos 5 meses,
me dio un ataque, ¿no?
Pero también comprendí cosas
que nos suceden a las mujeres
que vamos ascendiendo,
que vamos acercándonos al éxito,
donde siempre buscan mermar esos procesos
porque a los hombres jamás
se les va a poner en tela de juicio
su integridad, o su valor o su esfuerzo.
Obviamente, me he quedado
con todos los comentarios positivos,
con toda la gente que me apoyó
a lo largo de esta larga aventura
y que vieron mi constancia, mi evolución,
mis procesos, mis valores, mi disciplina.
Y el mensaje que fue muy claro.
Todas las personas que trabajamos duro
por lo que queremos lo podemos obtener
independientemente sea cual sea
nuestro género o el contexto social
del que vengamos.
Lo que necesitamos en México
son mujeres empoderadas
por dos grandes esferas:
el deporte y la educación.
Esta es una dualidad infalible
que nos va a permitir ser autónomas
y también ocupar el rol que queramos
en nuestra sociedad.
No nos conformemos nunca
con pequeñeces, con estereotipos,
con roles de género que ni hoy ni nunca
nos han definido como mujeres.
Porque una mujer puede ser bonita,
sensible, delicada, femenina,
pero también puede combinar eso
con su lado de lucha, perseverancia,
fuerza, determinación,
consecución de metas.
Una mujer en concreto
puede pegar tan fuerte como quiera,
puede correr tan rápido
como se lo proponga,
puede crear, imaginar, puede ejecutar,
pero lo que tenemos que hacer
es atrevernos a hacerlo.
A ser esas protagonistas
de nuestra historia.
Las invito a todas
a que nos levantemos de esos bancos
en los que por muchos años
nos han querido sentar.
Y a que luchemos, día a día,
por esa equidad de género,
por esa igualdad que urge
en cada esfera de nuestra sociedad.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)